Một chiều mùi muốn thống người, công an thành phố an nội tổ chức họp báo, công bố kết quả điều tra bất đầu của một số vua an trong lĩnh vật kinh tế và mùi trường với quy mô hạt động liên tình, zang thu linh tới hàng nghiên tỡ ông.
Cơ quan công an sách định từ năm 2018 đến nay, công ty sản xuất thương mại và dịch vụ vệ dịch liên đã sản xuất làm giả chất lượng và đưa ra từ thủ trên thị trường khoảng 8 triệu bình trở trái cất loại, với doanh thu bản hàng khoảng 1 nghiên tỡ ông.
Tương ngày 1 mô tháng 1 năm 2018 đến nay, công ty của phần định và chữ sản an phố làm giả chất lượng và tíu thu khoảng 2,5 in bình trở trái cất loại, zoanh thu khoảng 1,5 tỡ ông.
Quà khám sát, lượng trức năng phát hiện, tạm giữ một chăm sóm miệng nghiên tình một chăm mũ mũ mì bà bình trở trái nhắn hiệu ra gần các loại, cùng dây chuyển sản xuất và nhiều tài liệu có liên quan.
Công an thành phố Thông tin ngày 1 mô tháng chính, công an hà nội vui hợp với khoảng lĩ tị trường, bắt quả tăng nhân viên công ty của phần thực phẩm hi ra xá hoài đức hà nội, đang bơm tình trất tạo vấn mớ, biến thiên trâu thành bòa điều nhận.
Từ tháng 6,5 in không trăm 2 mì tư, đến khi bị phát hiện bắt giữ, các đối tượng đã sản xuất mề bốn tấn thiên trâu giả thiên bò, tư thu trên địa vàn thành phố Hà Nội, đã nắng nhà trang và thành phố Hổ Chí Minh, lượng trức năng thu giữ sống 15 tấn thiên trâu thiên bòa ra và tòn bộ máy móc phục vụ cho việc chế biến bà sản xuất thiên bò ra.
Mề bày tấn bò tình trất, dung đề bước vào thiên trâu tạo vấn mớ, hình thức giống thiên bòa gua nhiều khẩu.
Vịnh kiểm nhiệm bóng ra kết loạn, 2 mì thứ trên 2 mì chiến mẫu thiệt bò, thu giữ của công ty hira có ADN là thi trâu.
Bên cạnh đó, các quan điều tra đăng thiên hành giám định số vụ tình trất trên để sắc định có được tố gây hại cho sức khoảng người thư dùng.
Chức đó ngay mừng 2 tháng mười, công an hà Nội kìm chà sường xa sản xuất nước của Le Van Viet,
sinh năm 1997, chú phường lòng viên thành phố Hà Nội, bắt quả tăng các đối tượng đang dùng vỏi bơm nước mấy vào các vỏ mình là vì thu giữ hơn 5 trọng bình nước là VISA các loại,
mười chính lết và 1 tám phy năm lết.
Cơ quan điều tra sắc định từ tháng 8 đến thống mười năm 2018, Le Van Viet tưu thu khoảng 2 mìng mình nước là VISA,
giá gần 20 mìng đồng một bình tại Hà Nội.
Cơ quan cạnh sát điều tra, công an thành phố Hà Nội đã quyết định khởi tố phủ án hình sự, khởi tố bún bị cán về tội,
sản xuất, muốn bản hàng giả là nước tượng thực phẩm, quy định tại điều một chăm triếm mới ba, bộ lở thành sự.